so tell us what flagship does
yeah so flagship flagship is first and
foremost
a life science innovation company
we are we have our own way by which we
innovate which i'll tell you about
uh once we come up with something that's
worth
uh uh taking forward we form a company
to take that forward and so we also had
to figure out how to do venture creation
in a
systematic way we have our own capital
then we deploy into these companies
to help them grow for the first two
three years so up until then they
operate as
fully owned pieces of flagship and then
we spin them out
and we spin them out and for the first
time additional capital comes in
but by that time the culture the senior
leadership team
the early proof of concept the early
kind of customer or partner attraction
is there and
and it looks like a company ready to
eventually live its life on its own so
we're not interested in building kind of
subsidiaries
open-endedly every single thing we do
ends up becoming a company
or nothing but so we've become kind of a
creator of companies
around internal innovations now
sometimes these innovations draw from
external science and i can describe that
but but we're not only trying to find
science and find what to do with it and
create companies that's become
in vogue the last few years we've been
doing this for 18 years but we've ended
up in a place where
we think the sustainable way to do this
is to have your own innovation capacity
your own company creation capacity
initial growth
and then the companies have the
wherewithal to grow and
and and compete and thrive that's
fascinating so
so walk us through one example of a
company that
you guys have given adversity from the
start to
you know it's it's leaving the flagship
full um
there are many there's i think we've
we've been involved in doing about 50 of
these that are on based on internally
developed science and there's a whole
bunch more
that also include external but i'd say
one of the internally developed ones
that just recently went public i can
give us examples moderna
so moderna was an in and i'll tell you
kind of this we have this
fairly um let's say
prescribed process which you the way
people think about entrepreneurship and
innovation especially breakthrough
innovation
is that it is unruly it is chaotic it is
inspired
it's none of those things it's none of
those absolutely none of those things i
i have a completely contrarian view of
that and i've done it enough times in
enough different fields
that i think frankly just to be a little
controversial
i think that's an illusion in other
words i think that
because people haven't done that thing
before
it's exciting and you know unexpected to
them
but but actually pretty quickly it looks
like just another version of what
came before them because the historians
come and say well you know before there
was the ipad there was the ipod and
before that there was the
walkman etc and also when you look at it
that way you go why were you surprised
and that's when you realized that these
things are just evolving
and so i'll say i'll give you an example
in this company called modena but
before that i'll tell you that
underlying how we think you can do this
systematically
is the notion that breakthroughs aren't
made by people
they emerge and the most understood
not well understood but understood
version of emergence that we know about
is evolution
which is that if you do variation
iteration
selection and iteration systematically
you will
the winners will emerge and when they do
they will look surprising but actually
they're the result of that process
they're not some inspired thought that
has nothing to do with that process
so hold that thought as i give examples
they'll all be examples of that
and that actually does cause you know
one to think differently about being
possessive
about all these companies and all these
innovations we're not
we don't we don't go around saying we
invented this we may file a patent and
get an invention
but where these ideas come from are very
emergent so in modernist case
talking about emergence we we understood
by following the various scientific
advances
that people were playing around with
converting fibroblast cells into
what's called uh induced pluripotent
stem cells these are
you know if somebody wanted nobel prize
recently for this these are called
yamanaka factors so it turns out that if
you take
differentiated cells and you introduce a
couple of three different proteins
four of them specifically these cells
can de-differentiate and look like what
came before them stem cells
they're not normal stem cells but
they're close to being
stem cells and so why do that because
then you can differentiate it make other
cells
so that was the general field and in
that field there had been some people
particularly at upenn
and and then more recently at children's
hospital here in boston who had been
playing around with
using what's called mrna messenger rna
to use
these to to to go into cells and express
these proteins
why had they done that because turns out
this mrna they could actually get a
better
transformation of these cells and so we
were aware of this work
and and we started asking kind of just
what if questions
so your team is is reading scientific
papers is this in the area yeah in this
case
yeah exactly and it's we do this all the
time so basically we're you're in the
mix of this flow of knowledge
it's not about reading papers for us as
much as just i mean we are we are
talking to lots of people about lots of
different things
and then or somebody says hey by the way
you know i just saw this data
yeah and then and then we actually read
papers in hindsight in other words we
read papers once we have an idea of what
to do
as opposed to read papers to get an idea
per se because just you know the signal
to noise and papers is gigantic you
can't
yeah if you sit there and read a
thousand papers and then give you three
ideas
hard to do anything else so it's a i'm
sure that can be done too but we that's
not the way we approach it
anyway so long story short we we started
wondering for lots of reasons that
i can't almost reproduce because you'd
have to go back to 2010
in the summer and whatever else was
being thought of at the time
so understand by that time we had about
20 people that were doing this
type of activity in various combinations
for a living yeah and and so that's uh
that's it's important because these
these ideas kind of get mixed and moved
around this is not a
one person thinking deeply is not going
to get there
so so we start asking you know can you
think about
we said why isn't there no drug that is
based on mrna
now if you go back 10 years drugs were
made out of proteins and small molecules
there had been an effort to use viruses
to introduce genes into the body called
gene therapy
and you know a person had been had died
early on and that thought field was shut
down
and there really was no other variation
to proteins and small molecules
and there had been some efforts to try
to make you know not to get too detailed
but
other small dna rna molecules anti-sense
what's called and
and and we were aware of all this but
we're saying why why don't people
actually use this microrna molecule
and that's just a thought experiment and
you can go and ask answer that question
so you raise that problem you raise you
raise a what if problem you don't say
you know initially we don't start with
we need to cure melanoma
we don't start a problem you know what
good is this mrna that can transform
cells because it's not good for anything
other than that
but we kind of abstracted and said is
there a combination of a solution
and a problem that we can identify
simultaneously
around this space and if there isn't one
then we move on and in this case that's
part of our methodology
in this case what we concluded was that
people had tried and failed
10 years earlier we understood why they
tried and failed we realized that there
was no obvious fix to it
but there was a direction of fixing that
you could modify chemically some of
these rna molecules
and they at least hinted that if you
kept doing that there may be better ways
we had no proof
there was no academic literature that
said this can be done
now we could have waited for that but we
probably would have been five six years
because
now there is academic papers from which
we could have started companies but
our our whole thing is to almost mine
this you know science of the future to
try to solve problems of today
versus mind the science of today to
solve problems of the future
and that is exactly backwards and and
and and it's not any better it's just
that you look at the world differently
so
publications give you evidence for what
you want to do
but that's not why they published those
things they were thinking of a very
different thing
do you know what i'm saying so in that
regard that's that's a little bit so
in modernist case we identified
well the other thing that we do a very
integral part of what we do is that we
don't do this in a vacuum
so we go out and talk to people about
our
hypotheses these are not you're not
afraid of people taking your ideas no
and i'll tell you why so we we have this
no
so we use in order to try to create an
evolution so we're trying to create an
evolutionary
environment how do you do that uh the
scientific method
uses hypotheses and experimentation so
we actually do the same thing
we create value hypotheses we basically
say
i will take an mrna molecule formulate
it with this
agent stick it into muscle use muscle
none of it is true none of it's been
done before
but it's just a starting point we then
go with that
to a handful of folks that are both
experts and non-experts in the field
super important thing if you're going to
practice this kind of work is that
experts
actually are not the people who are
going to give you an idea of how to do
things dramatically differently
because they became experts by already
doing something dramatically differently
and now they're defending their
territory so if you go to talk to
somebody and say
can this be done out here most people we
talk to
they can tell you precisely why it can't
be done which is really valuable
from a selection pressure standpoint but
not the source of
kind of and here's a completely
different way so so
other people though who don't have
expertise but have
interesting creativity so what we do is
we take our hypotheses and it's never
one
because one of the things we've learned
is that if you start with one starting
point
you only locally uh search the space
around it
so we sample multiple different points
so it might be
how about mrna as a way to make more
proteins and
you know fermenter how about so around
the theme we come up with totally
different valuables we try to identify
and then we we put a starting point then
we start talking and
what's what's been interesting and a
great learning exercise over the years
that we've seen
is that if you go to somebody with a
you know a bad idea but you actually
present it in a precise way
they will they will tell you why it's a
bad idea and in that transaction
something happens they feel smarter yes
and you get selection pressure
and so the way our process works is that
we actually do this
with multiple people so when you said um
you know aren't you afraid they're going
to take your idea
what are they thinking we just made it
up yes there's zero effect to it
literally zero factor just imagining
exactly it's we're just a hypothesis and
they know it
because then they tell us what proof do
you have is a nun so then they still
engage because it's a almost
when we talk to these folks and this is
what we're known for we create a bit of
a
a an expert free zone in the sense that
you see look
these scientists you know here we are at
harvard and mit stuff
these people go to the the meetings of
their fields and they
cannot say something that does not seem
unbelievably smart
and reasonable actually make the point
let me
caveat reasonableness in my view is
like the gravitational force that keeps
innovation from happening
because people enforce reasonableness
in the scientific world on what you are
allowed to say
you go publish something in the
literature that's not reasonable
to the reviewers you can't get killed
i've done a whole study on that
right so ask yourself the question why
is it
that we think that the only innovations
worth working on start their life
reasonably
in fact i can show you many innovations
that are now
you know accepted as real transformative
things every one of them started life
unreasonably and yet we go look for them
in reasonable places by reasonable
people
who are using reasonableness filters to
kill them
so because we knew that this was not the
first thing i had done
we kind of say look let's just let's
forget reasonableness for a second just
think with us
and they tell us bad idea somebody in
japan had tried it experiment won't work
and we keep tweaking and tweaking and
tweaking this is different than
kanek is you hear a lot in in silicon
valley speak kind of
in a pivoting this is not pivoting
evolution is the master pivot
it's like non-stop pivoting right
there's nothing to pivot from and two
you're just adapting and surviving so
that mindset
is super important now what happens is
over time things emerge
or they don't but they emerge where you
the next person you talk to goes
i don't they can't find fault with it
you know that because it frustrates them
and then they start telling you well do
you have any proof and you go no no i
just made this up it's just that we've
been anyway
and then that point is when we go into a
lab for the first time
and then and only then do we test the
idea now you can't test it
fully you can't test it where you know
because it takes years and years
but but we try to and one of the
expertise we we've developed over the
years
is how to to figure out what to test
first
and and this in you know in life science
you can't use these words
killer experiment because you know life
sciences can kill
but but you want to do the killer
experiment early yes
and so figuring out what's the killer
experiment or two or three or four
that if it if it doesn't fail allows you
to go forward
that's the trick and we do that in our
shop so in modernist case
we spent a couple million dollars about
six months
doing a set of key things but for which
we would not have proceeded so
we knew the idea had morphed and evolved
and it had some some resilience to it
we went into labs and asked specific
questions once we saw that actually some
of the things we were
hypothesizing could be done partially we
then decided okay
let's form the best economic value
creation engine known to mankind which
is a startup
in my view i'm biased and then we deploy
that startup to go after that value
pool in as many different ways as we can
you